what there's cardi b news what's the
more here we go cardi b
files to divorce offset wants custody of
culture
okay so there you go so now cardi b's
getting a divorce she's on the market
i'm dm when i saw that she was trending
i naturally assumed that after her
legendary
uh interview with former vice president
presidential nominee biden
i naturally thought she was trending
because she was being considered for a
position on the supreme court
but i was wrong yeah i was wrong she's
getting no she's getting a divorce from
from a rapper named offset because who
the [ __ ] is offset
i uh is he one of the migos guys pimp
who's offset what song does
what song does offset had and what what
crimes have you [ __ ] been on a tour
bus to witness
sexually assaulted women uh he's in
migos and they have a bunch of hit songs
but they're kind of coming down from
their fame now so this is a little bit
bad for him
got it okay there you go so it's a
little bad but
i saw candace owens and cardi b beef and
two what was that about
well they just got into an argument over
politics and um
you know i'm gonna have to go slight
advantage to uh kenz owens on that
just because she you know i think she
just knows more words
so that that that went her way but you
know what i don't think
offset if he's heartbroken you know it's
it's tough when you're
when you date someone that famous you're
going to see her everywhere but the
amount
and it really reminds you the love you
had but with the amount of plastic
surgery that she's had already
and that she's gonna have in the future
you won't he won't even
recognize her anymore to the point get
heartbroken you know what i mean
very very very good point we really
hope you enjoyed that episode whatever
it was about this is just a stock thing
that we're taping on to every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild